- Welcome back, everybody.
Our next guest is one of our favorites.
Her podcast is called
"Sincerely Fortune With Fortune Feimster".
It's available wherever
you get your podcasts.
And also make sure to
check out her website
for her fall tour dates.
Please Welcome, Fortune Feimster! (claps)
(gentle upbeat music)
You got, like, a slow jam.
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
- I love that they had you walk out
to, like, a slow jam.
That was cool.
- They know some sexy stuff is happening
(Kelly laughs)
right now.
- I love you so much.
Well, you got married-
- I got married. Yes!
- Since the last time I saw...
Congratulations!
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
- I was actually on your show
like, right before we got married.
And I was like,
"Kelly, I'm getting married
in a couple of weeks."
- [Kelly] I love the color of your suit.
- Look at that.
Yeah, we did a last minute wedding where
we weren't really...
We didn't think we were
gonna be able to get married
this past year with the pandemic
'cause we were gonna
have, like, a real thing.
And then in, like, September, October,
we were just like,
"Let's just get married.
Like, why are we waiting?"
- Yeah.
- And so...
- Save your money and buy
something cool like a house.
- (laughs) I know, for real.
- [Kelly] Rather than a wedding.
- Yeah, so we planned
it, like, three weeks.
We had five friends get tested
and we kinda did an outdoor thing
as you see on the beach.
And we ended up Zooming our families
but I didn't think about that in advance
'cause you just don't think about,
you know, Zooms in weddings.
And so like, 10 minutes
before the ceremony, I'm like,
"Oh," like, "We should
probably Zoom our families."
And so, I'm like frantically
trying to get a Zoom link going
and like,
- I don't know how to do that.
the internet was down.
And so, you know, we're
like sending it out.
We're like, we hope we
remembered to send, like,
send it to everybody.
We forgot a few people.
- I think that, you
know, it's a good pass,
the whole global pandemic thing.
- [Fortune] Yeah.
- It's a good, like, "Hey, we tried."
- We tried.
- There was effort.
- Yeah. And I've, for
sure, saved a lot of money.
'Cause my family, we're
Southern, we like to eat.
That would've bankrupted me.
- Just the food.
- And drinks.
If they're Southerners,
the food and drinks.
- My mom doesn't like
eating the fancy food.
She's like, "You got any flatters?"
- [Kelly] Flatters? (laughs)
Fried chicken.
- I don't wanna eat this Ahi Tuna.
(both laughing)
- But anyway, so I noticed
your Southern friend, Brenda,
is really, you know, enjoying
her Kelly Clarkson cup.
- Kelly...
- Yup?
- Brenda is a big fan of yours.
And yeah, she got the Kelly Clarkson cup
and she takes it every
time she's in the hot tub
when she takes a dip.
- Hi, y'all. It's me, Brenda.
I am
so happy right now.
I am in a hot tub taking a dip.
I got on my favorite
turquoise bathing suit
and my favorite visor.
I got my favorite cup over there
with my favorite talk
show host, Kelly Clarkson.
(both laughing)
- She loves it.
And so, I do this character Brenda
and every time I post a video as Brenda,
and I have that Kelly Clarkson
mug, the Swig cup in my hand,
I swear to God, I get like 200 messages
from people being like,
"How do I buy that Kelly Clarkson mug?"
(Kelly laughs)
And I'm like, "What? (laughs)"
So I'm like, "I'll let Kelly know."
She should sell that as merch, but...
- [Kelly] We should.
- People love that cup.
- Okay.
- And, yeah, Brenda is
a big fan of your show.
She watches it all the time.
- Is Brenda also the one
that was on the like,
Peloton-looking bike?
- That's Deb.
- That's Deb. I was
like, Deb had me rolling.
I was crying. I was laughing so hard.
What song, "Ride That
Train"? Was it, "Come On..."?
- "Come On Ride That Train", yeah.
- And you were just going
for it on that bike.
- I guess I was bored in quarantine.
I created a lot of characters.
And Deb is a spin instructor
who actually never spins.
(Kelly laughs)
She just sits on...
She just either sits at her
desk or sits at her spin bike
then she goes, "Come on,
everybody! Get on your bikes!"
(both laughing)
I did get on my bike that one time
and tried to ride to
"Come On Ride That Train".
- It's my favorite thing you've ever done.
- Deb got winded.
- [Kelly] Deb was amazing.
- The song...
Your outfit was, at one
point, it was so great.
- It's a lot of spandex.
(both laughing)
- All spandex.
- All spandex. Well,
you mentioned our cup.
And soon, we will have
our own swag store...
- Wow!
- Online.
We're still new. We're just, you know...
- I wanna credit Brenda for that.
- Exactly.
(both laughing)
But in the meantime, in honor of Brenda,
let's make the house seats happy.
So Swig is a fashion-oriented
drink wear brand
that offers a variety
of insulated tumblers
with designs that match current trends
and your own personal style.
Now, everyone will get to have
a wine tumbler like Brenda.
(Fortune gasps)
Because we're all getting
a $200 Swig gift card.
- Yes! Yes, look at that!
Come on now.
- Look what Brenda's doing.
- Brenda is changing lives.
- She's making ripples.
- If y'all don't take a dip in the hot tub
with your Swig cup, you're missing out.
(both laughing)
- And then go ride your bike like Deb.
All right, well, I have
something for you as well.
Because this is the fifth time
that you've been on the show.
- Okay. Yeah.
- Mhm.
And usually, we gave
you a Team Kelly jacket
for your fourth time,
but you ambushed us last
time and we missed it,
so our bad.
So we may-
- I'm so sorry to interrupt. I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God. This is so tacky...
Oh, yeah, spent the night in your studio.
- Okay, see, see.
We made you a special happy
belated Team Kelly jacket.
This is special. No one has this one.
Justin, come here.
- Oh, my gosh.
For real?
- No one has this one.
- Oh, my God!
- Look at that.
Happy Belated Team Kelly.
- You, guys.
- There you go.
- Look at that.
Oh, my God.
- But yours is special.
No one has this special writing on it.
- [Fortune] No one has it.
- 'Cause you're special.
- Oh, my God. I'm gonna sleep in this.
- It's soft, actually.
- Yeah.
- I always, you know what, it sucks
when you actually come up
with, like, merch from tours
something your jacket like this
and you love wearing it 'cause
it's like soft and nice.
But then you're like,
"I can't wear this out.
People are gonna- I'm
gonna look like a douche.
Like, I'm walking around
with my name on it."
- I've worn your mask-
- No, it's different! If
it's yours, I'll wear it.
- (laughs) I had to wear it?
- But if it's your own, you're like,
"Oh, I'm just in my Team Kelly jacket."
- Kelly, I wear my own ice cream merch.
- You're funny though! I don't
think I can pull that off.
I'm gonna start doing it.
- You need to start wearing Team Kelly.
- [Kelly] I'm gonna beat that talk.
- Team Kelly all the way.
- You're gonna see me in my
Team Kelly jacket everywhere.
All right, well, "Sincerely
Fortune with Fortune Feimster's"
available wherever you get your podcast.
And check out Fortune's website
for her fall tour dates.